product not yet rated  on nexus shining jewel of the galaxy a  while unexplored paradise lost to the  ages deep in the Starla's expands well  guess what now you can make this alien  paradise your next adventure how are the  ship and enjoy the ride explore the  ruins of a mysterious hyper advanced  civilization escape blakney conflict and  meet the neighbors yes everyone's a  friend our nexus and hold on to those  self-sealing space pants because bam  there's more pack now and you'll get a  once-in-a-lifetime opportunity your very  own rocket house yes on rocket house is  it a rocket is it a house it's both  it'll make you say look at me i live in  a rocket so start your journey to nexus  today protostar pre-selling you the home  of your dreams for money the furthest  our cooperation is not responsible for  injuries you may incur in your rush to  take advantage of this limited time  offer  you  you